this was met when you upload these
pictures I'm telling you behind the
scenes with one of two reactions from
men either fathers who have daughters
across the world groaning because they
can't let their daughter follow Ariel
winter on Instagram anymore or the sound
of personal skin-on-skin contact for a
bunch of teenagers in their bedrooms who
are fans of Ariel winter
Ariel winter has been a subject of a lot
of discussion this week let's roll this
clip to set it up she took some
revealing pictures I guess you would say
an Instagram snapchat whatever it is and
people commented lots of positive lots
of negative and so it became an entire
commentary on whether the internet is
sexist and how men react to it and about
body shaming we do find go to images
just go to the image okay so this was
the image that she put up for those
listening to rest really okay look at
that picture listen there's one thing
you see when you look at that picture
it's a great fantastic picture and it
was all can you just show us the next
picture real quick just so we can see it
so she put up these ultra revealing
pictures and I guess some people
commented in sexually ways and saying
hey hey you know don't worry this is
just the industry
it's sexism here's the deal it's not
sexism okay let me explain something
this is actually worse it's more unfair
to men and let me give you a little bit
of a reality check okay Ariel winter and
people think she's brave by the way I
love how the body shaming I love how the
body they talk about body shame like I'm
proud of my body and they take a picture
where they've clearly taken 12 takes
with all the Instagram filters let me
change this shadow in the vignette let
me change the contrast no puppy filter
no puppy and and they're doing the
vacuum stomach pose like like Frank Zane
circa mr. Olympia but not just shown the
frumpy picture of them in a bikini from
paparazzi it's their best possible pose
to say they're proud of their body
they're just as vain the problem with
this is it's it's vanity it's shallow
everything disguised as though it's
female pride so she puts these pictures
up people respond people say it's sexist
here's the deal if a guy says show me
your boobs is that sexist doesn't he
hates women but it's at the very least
inappropriate ungentlemanly say
misogynistic sure you shouldn't do that
however if like this woman the lady
comes up or aryl winter and says here
are my tits and a man says hmm I approve
or disapprove zazz you see with comments
on the internet hmm I like said tits
sorry like I said get your kids out of
the room when we're talking about this
by the way almost always if you're
showing your boobs you have to have a
big swing and a Miss for the feedback to
not be positive okay we're fans of the
boobs you're graded on a curve quite
literally the feedback was from some
people hey you look great very sexual
and some people said put some clothes on
here's the deal
you're the one who sexualized it that is
what men will see you can't get angry if
they respond in a sexual way when you
say here are my tits
there is nothing unnatural I'm not
saying men should sexually assault or
act on these urges but this was met when
you upload these pictures I'm telling
you behind the scenes with one of two
reactions from men either fathers who
have daughters across the world groaning
because they can't let their daughter
follow Ariel winter and Instagram
anymore or the sound of personal
skin-on-skin contact for a bunch of
teenagers in their bedrooms who are fans
of Ariel winter we try and whitewash
this like this is a sexy picture on
Instagram or snapchat oh they have a
picture of Ariel winter above their bed
let me tell you how do you an idea how
disgusting how awful it is what teenage
boys are doing with pictures like this
in their bedroom okay look at this come
on do you know it is let's let's be real
about it it's not an art critique these
people aren't looking and examining it's
masturbatorium material for tweens who
watch modern family do you an idea how
disgusting the actual physical uses are
for these posters that are printed out
at Kinkos and you're mad about a comment
on Instagram you have no idea as to how
disgusting the teenage boy male mind is
I'm not excusing sexual assault at all
but it's like if you put a piece of
bacon on a dog's nose and he's the most
well behaved dog and he sits there not
saying he can eat the bacon but you
laugh or say he's a bad dog because he's
drooling at the bacon you upload a
picture of your gift here are my titties
and a guy saying hmm I like those
breasts and then you accuse him of being
sexist and then say we're gonna stay
strong no body shaming here's an idea
how about learning something how about
reading a book how about learning to act
and stop being the weakest link on
Modern Family to begin with then you can
show people your tits and accuse them of
being sexist it is so great and young
men are just constantly guilted it is
such a bait and trap for young men here
are my breasts and then they reprimand
young men for liking that they get to
look at breasts of course older men like
looking at breasts but that's feminism
now sexualize yourself and blame the men
who react sexually
hae-jin laughing this video is taken
from the full weekly podcast louder with
Crowder subscribe by clicking it
Jarrod's laughing because that he's act
he just got shot the loss of blood is
making him delirious who shot him
guilty